alrighty we're about to look at ami
horowitz's latest video his man on the
street video can view his whole video
over at the daily wire youtube channel
apparently ami went around new york
and asked a bunch of new yorkers about
whether they were ready for unity
and what they thought unity meant i'm
amy horowitz and i'm here in the east
village
now the election is over the democrats
have been pushing the message of
togetherness
and unity but unity on whose terms
how important is it the value of
toleration and accepting of other people
it's the most important thing extremely
important
you know this divisiveness in this
country
is uh has become terrible you know be
compassionate and understanding
and be as supportive as you can i'll
never understand fully why people spend
all their time you know trying to hate
on one
group it's very important um
it's it's one of the most important
things i'm one of the most
uh tolerant people because i'm one of
the most empathetic people
do republicans have any value at all
[Music]
no you're delusional
yeah you can pause right there for a
second i mean that's that's of course
exactly right right and then the minute
once you say that tolerance is the
highest value once you say that
tolerance is the only value
then where you go from there is that
anybody who has a value system different
from that
as their chief value system is a
horrible person and see this is the the
self-defeating logic
of complete tolerance is that you can
tolerate everybody except somebody who
you consider to be
intolerant this actually has a deeper
ideological route it goes back to
herbert marquis who was a frankfurt
school
theorist a neo-marxist theorist in the
1960s 1970s he actually proposed
something what he called repressive
tolerance
he said that in order for tolerance to
flourish you have to make sure
that groups that are intolerant are not
allowed to flourish and that means that
you have to shut them down and never
allow them to talk again
so tolerance requires harsh handed
intolerance that's the only way that you
can actually
solve the problem of intolerance
mindless racist
there's a lot of immorality in them
every living thing
on this earth is a miracle republicans
yeah super important you know it's not
always going to be fair
you know it's not and now everybody's
going to be happy by the end but it's
important to
talk things through how do we unify yeah
exactly how or is the value of
compromises
it's important i mean you do have to
compromise you do have to compromise
there are areas of the common ground
you know they can reach areas we could
compromise
there is compromise for instance uh you
know the
climate change which is at the top of
the list
and so there's a compromise to be had
there there is a compromise to be had
yes so for example like they would give
on like
cafe standards that's what if you have
unlike
fracking well fracking is a touchy issue
can you compromise on something around
climate change to give the republicans
something
yeah it would depend it would depend on
what it was for instance they want to go
into anwar the uh
the arctic national reserve to start
digging that up so you're okay with that
no i am not no no no no no is there
something you're willing to compromise
on climate change to give the
republicans something they want
well they uh they could uh
cut you know as far as carbon emissions
goes
so would you be willing to have a little
more heart a little more comprehension
no so there really isn't anything you're
willing to compromise on well i don't
know
i don't know i'm getting the feeling
that you don't fully understand them
[Laughter]
can you compromise on
absolutely not there is no compromise
okay by the way
let's just stop it right there for a
second so first of all a compromise on
climate change is like the easiest
compromise there is so for example many
of the things that these folks are
saying they oppose
like for example fracking fracking is
one of the chief reasons
why the carbon emissions in the united
states have dropped because people are
using natural gas
and oil as opposed to coal powered
emissions right coal is
much more carbon intensive fracking is
much less carbon intensive and yet
somehow fracking is the bad guy if if
omni were to ask these people how do you
feel about nuclear power my guess is
they would all say no nuclear power is
extremely bad as well
we can't have nuclear power so we're
gonna have like windmills
and he he happens to be right like
they're all these sort of
words that get thrown around in politics
particularly by pundits where people
don't unpack them
at all because once you unpack them it
becomes very clear
that folks are very very inconsistent in
their own view of the world they're
tolerant except for the people they hate
and they're in favor of compromise
except for the people they don't want to
compromise with they're totally in favor
of decreasing government spending unless
it means actually you know picking
programs where you decrease government
spending
and they also happen to be totally in
favor of defunding the police until it
happens that there are no police on
their block
so people don't think through with any
level of consistency their own politics
obviously
ami is doing a great job of exposing
that here we're at a point now where
there's no compromise
if you're in coal learn how to make
solar panels oh yeah that'll work
you know but that's compromise that's as
far as i go
there really isn't room for compromise i
mean
no 100 no can you compromise on
universal health care
well i can't see not giving it to
everyone can you compromise on universal
health care
um no i mean ultimately no i don't
believe so is there room to compromise
on universal health care
i guess not no no other people
governments can do it
so i don't understand why we do right by
compromise they mean you shut the hell
up and you give in to everything that we
could possibly want
right this is and part of this is just
the moral binary that's created
by the media is that they're not complex
answers to complex questions like how do
you provide health care and the reality
is that they're very
they're a bunch of different versions of
how you provide health care right
they're they're
largely privatized systems like
singapore there are totally
nationalized systems like the uk there's
a lot of variation and gradation in
there and the
healthcare system in the united states
is sort of a grab bag of various
policies so there's there's plenty of
room for compromise on health care and
there has been historically a lot of
compromise
on healthcare but no no nobody actually
wants to contemplate that so they just
go with the easy one-size-fits-all
answer
universal healthcare for all what about
an issue like um
i think that one's pretty clear-cut it's
yes or no i think there
is no room yeah yeah
i don't think so is there a compromise
that have you had on abortion
no no no it's their body it's absolutely
your body
income inequality should we compromise
no i think
we should have you should just have
equality i've been compromising fighting
for
this quality that's a
that's a heavy question a compromise is
there a compromise for
i can't think of one right now honestly
the one percent of this country are just
way too have too much
no no you can't cover okay so words that
we have learned from mommy that mean
nothing for these folks are tolerance
and compromise
that's exciting stuff and that that is
not a complete shock
at all because of course people who like
to think of themselves as tolerant
and moderate are in fact very intolerant
and quite immoderate
as it turns out on issues that are
important to you
really shouldn't help their lives yeah
on issues that are important to you
really shouldn't accomplish right right
yeah and issues that are right for like
society and humanity all right so yeah
maybe earlier i said compromising but
maybe now that you're
making me see them yeah do you do you
think that
um we can unify with republicans
like is is there a real way to do that
uh maybe
in the far future i don't think right
now there is no you don't see any way to
unify the public yeah
no not not to my knowledge yeah and that
is the end
of the story right democrats joe biden
these folks they say unity you need
unity but very often what they mean
is nothing resembling unity because
there is a real division on core values
in the country right now
there's one side of the country that is
in
is basically in hock to people who
believe that the united states is
systemically racist
that it is filled with evil and
inequality
and cruelty and that we should aim for a
completely different goal we should aim
for something
more european in nature and there are
folks who believe that individual
liberty is paramount
and it's very hard to square that circle
so we i mean honestly like
we ought to recognize the actual
real-life differences and then we
maybe we can have some clarification on
what we actually agree on because we've
gotten to the point where
the american flag is contentious we've
basic family units are contentious if
everything is contentious
then there's really no room for
everybody to to get along but we're
gonna have to find some common ground or
this is all going to collapse in on
itself
very very quickly and i think that is
what uh ami is featuring
right there by the way i think that if
you asked these folks are you friends
with any republicans like can you name a
single friend of yours who voted for
trump
my guess is they would say no whereas if
you ask most republicans can you name a
single person
who you are friendly with who voted for
a democrat the answer is i'm sure in
much larger numbers yes i think there's
a reason for that
and that is it turns out that the folks
who proclaim themselves the most
tolerant are usually the most intolerant
because they have deemed themselves
the beneficiaries of the moral high
ground they are the
architects of a better moral universe in
which they get to rule
from on high alrighty well that brings
us to the end of this video but if you
want to see ami's entire video go check
it out over at the dailywire youtube
page in the comments
tell us what you'd like us to react to
next